beautiful and mysterious sci-fi world
this is just one part of the zetta halo
ring
the largest most wide open environment
we've ever built
and we can't wait for you to explore it
[Music]
the heart of halo is spartan 117
the master chief in the next chapter of
the chief's story
you'll face his greatest challenge yet
but
you're not alone in the fight
the main batteries are shut down we're
stuck out here
[Music]
you have one bullet against an entire
army
what can you do on your own i told you
it's enough so i see
[Music]
i need you to understand
there's not much time
how would you live your life
what happened where is cortana
the rogue ai known as cortana is gone
she's been deleted
how by you of course not
did you hit your head or something don't
you remember
my instructions were to enter this
installation imitate cortana and lock
her down for retrieval
yours were to take her back to the
infinity for deletion
so if it wasn't you
okay then
there's something else on successful
deployment
my deletion routine was supposed to
complete
still here good
good something stopped your deletion
we need to find out why but
this wasn't the mission the missions
changed
they always do are you sure
[Music]
you